مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا هذه النافذه الجديده
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه في هذه النافذه كالعاده نستضيف
المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز
دويري بدايه مشاهدينا سنتابع اخر تطورات
المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه
الانتشار العسكري الاسرائيلي وكيفيه تحرك
هذا الانتشار من من من طاقه الى اخرى في
قطاع غزه نتعرف عليه مع سلام خضر على
الخريطه التفاعليه تفضلي سلام شكرا حسن
تطورات اليوم يمكن ان نقول في قطاع غزه
انها نوعيه على اكثر من مستوى لاسما في
مساله الاستهدافات التي نفذتها كتائب
القسام وفصائل المقاومه في قطاع غزه سنبدا
من المنطقه الشماليه المنطقه الشماليه
استمرت فيها الاشتباكات رغم ان القوات
الاسرائيليه نفذت مجموعه من التحركات
والانسحابات او ما تسميها اعاده التموضع
انسحبت من مناطق في جباليا والشيخ رضوان
كانت تتمركز فيها الاليات الاسرائيليه
انسحبت ولدينا صور اقمار صناعيه تفيد
بتحرك هذه الاليات وخلو تقريبا جباليا من
جباليا ومحيط جباليا والشيخ رضوان من محيط
الاليات الاسرائيليه ايضا كان هناك اليات
متمركزه عند الشاطئ او المنطقه الساحليه
المباشره اجرت منها انسحابات عديده ولكن
دفعت بهذه الاليات بحسب ما يبدو الى مناطق
اخرى لا سما الى مخيم البريج التي تحاول
الدخول اليه منذ فتره استمرت في ال ايضا
في المنطقه الشماليه الاشتباكات شديده جدا
في حي الدرج وحي التفاح هذان الحيان متخم
لقطاع غزه بل هما عفوا لمدينه غزه من
مداخل مدينه غزه لا تزال الاشتباكات فيهما
ضاريه جدا تحت ضربات المقاومه تضطر القوات
الاسرائيليه لاعاده التموضع الانسحاب
قليلا ثم تستغل ساعات الليل بحسب
المعلومات الميدانيه في محاوله للتقدم
اكثر الى داخل هذين الحيين والقتال لا
يزال مستمرا فيه بالانتقال الى المنطقه
الوسطى في قطاع غزه المنطقه الوسطى هي
المكان الاحدث الذي قالت فيه اسرائيل قبل
نحو اسبوع انها ستبدا عمليه وصفتها بالموس
في لا سما في مخيم البريج الهجوم بدا
بالفعل على مخيم البريج من عده مناطق من
عده ايام والهجمات تاتيه من الشمال
والشمال الشرقي تحاول ايضا القوات
الاسرائيليه التوغل الى مخيم البريج لكنها
لم تفلح بذلك حتى الان هناك اشتباكات
مباشره واستهداف اليوم ايضا اعلنت كتائب
القسام انها استهدفت طائره في منطقه شرق
غزه لم يحددوا الجغرافيا
بطريقه واضحه ولكن شرق غزه بدوره يشهد
حراكا عسكريا تعود اليه او تتراجع اليه
القوات الاسرائيليه تحت ضغط الضات
الميدانيه ومنه تشن هجمات وايضا النصيرات
اليوم تعرضت لقصف سنخت في منطقه خان يونس
القتال مستمر هناك خسائر للوحدات المقاتله
وهناك استهداف قبل دقائق لطائره مروحيه
قالت القسام انها استهدفتها مع كتائب
المجاهدين بصاروخ ارض جو من دون ان تعطي
معلومات اضافيه ولكن المزيد من هذه
التطورات حسن وقراءه في صور الاقوال
الصناعيه نعود اليك شكرا سلام وتحديدا
الاقمار الصناعيه وا الصور التي تشير الى
التموضع الجديد لقوات الاحتلال سنتابع هذه
الصور في لحظات هذه هي الصور لكن كما يبدو
من التاريخ سياده اللواء هي قبل
حوالى يعني حوالي اسبوع يعني هذه الاولى
في 26 هذه في 3112 وبالتالي مر على الصوره
الثانيه عده ايام هنا كانت الاليات م
واجده وهذه الاليات انسحبت طبعا هذا جاء
ضمن خطه الانسحاب الرئيسيه ليس في هذه
المنطقه هذه الصور تمثل هذه المنطقه لكن
معظم المناطق غرب مدينه غزه انسحبت منها
جميعها تقريبا وبقيت فقط في المنطقه
الشرقيه يعني هذه الصور تقريبا هي تؤكد ما
ما ذهب اليه جيش الاحتلال عندما تحدث عن
اجراء عمليات انسحاب فهذه احد الصور نعم
هذه الصور اين يعني
لا انها في بيت
لا منطقه منطقه بيت لاهيه وبالتالي تم
الانسحاب
منها الى مكان اخر الان بصوره عامه هو كان
يقاتل ثلاثه فرق في المنطقه تم الابقاء
على اربعه الويه ثلاثه فرق 12 لواء تم سحب
ثمانيه الويه نعم قسم منها كانت من ضمن
الالويه الخمسه التي تم الحديث عن اعاده
تسريحها و خرجت الى كان الحديث انها سترسل
احتمال ترسل الى الجبهه الشماليه الى غير
ذلك لكن هذه جمحه عادت الى غلاف غزه وما
وراء غلاف غزه طيب هذه في بيت لاهيه بيت
لاهيه نعم هذه الصوره المقارنه هذه اعتقد
بالشيخ رضوان بالشيخ رضوان بالشيخ رضوان
الان هذه منطقه البركه وبالتالي الصوره
الاولى تبين لك وجود بعض الاليات الصوره
الثانيه لا يوجد اي اثر للاليات كما جرى
في بيت لاهيه جرى في غرب الشيخ رضوان او
في حي الشيخ رضوان طيب ولكن يعني يبقى
السؤال عن الهدف من هذا الانسحاب هذا جاء
ضمن التحول للمرحله الثالثه هكذا ح تحدث
الجيش الاسرائيلي والاحتلال وقال بانه
يجري عمليات انسحاب وهذا تحدثنا عنه في
اكثر من مقابله انه بدا بالانسحاب بدا
بالانسحاب في البدايه من الحي الشرقي في
الشيخ رضوان ومن ثم من الحي الغربي من
الشيخ رضوان انسحب من منطقه جباليا ولم
يبقي الا على زاويه انسحب من اطراف مخيم
جباليه فهو اجر كما قلت لك سحب ثمانيه
الويه وبالتالي ه الصور ت تشير الى مناطق
محدده بينما هو الانسحاب انسحاب رغم رغم
ذلك يعني رغم الانسحابات نحن نشهد في اكثر
من منطقه تحديدا في غزه اشتباكات ما زالت
مع انا ا قلت لك انسحب من الجزء الغربي من
غزه بدءا من
اي الشيخ عجلين تل الهواء الرمال الجنوبي
الرمال محيط مخيم الشاط جباليا هذه كلها
انسحب منها وانسحب ل الشيخ رضوان وبقي في
المنطقه الشرقيه في منطقه التفاح والشجاع
والدرج وجبل الرييس هذه لا تزال الاربع
الويه موجوده في المنطقه الشرقيه الثمانيه
الويه تم سحبها قسم منها ارسل الى المنطقه
الوسطى الى منطقه البريج وقسم باعتبار
كانت هي تقريبا معظمها الويه احتياط وتم
سحبها على اساس تعزيز البعد الاقتصادي على
ذكر على ذكر البريج ايضا هناك
صور
مقارنه ل ل انسحاب الاليات حتى من البريج
في الوسط البريج الوضع مختلف الان في
منطقه البريج هو عمليه قتال متحرك تتقدم
تواجه
مقاومه تعود مره ثانيه لكن في صوره اطلعت
عليها منطقه القراره القراره في في الجنوب
هذه هي القر هذه منطقه القراره هذه الصور
تظهر لك تموضع الاليات من 24 ل 31 لم
تختلف الصوره لم تختلف الصوره بقيت كما
كما هي اي ان القوات بقيت عالقه في
تلك الفتره وبعد ذلك بعد 31 بدات تتحرك
باتجاه الجنوب ام باتجاه مدينه خان يونس
ودخلت في منطقه الاطراف الشماليه من خان
يونس ووصلت مع شارع صلاح الدين و شارع
السكه وشارع جمال عبد الناصر عاده ما تسمي
ذلك لواء فايز اعاده تموضع صحيح اذا كانت
للعوده للوراء اعاده تموضع اذا كانت حركه
اماميه عمليات بتصبح تطوير العمليات
الهجوميه في الحاله الاولى اعاده تموضع او
انتشار او انسحاب بغض النظر هذا يعتمد على
العمق والمكان الذي ذهبت له في الحاله
الثانيه لا هو تطوير العمليه الهجوم في اي
منطقه يجري الان تطوير العمل العسكري في
منطقه البريج بصوره واضحه جدا جدا حيث ان
هناك قتال شرس جدا البريج من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تهاجم هناك محاوله الاستفاده من
الثغره ما بين البريج والنصيرات وبالتالي
وهناك محاوله احاطه وبدات تهاجم النصيرات
من المنطقه الغربيه فهناك العمليات على
قدم وساق وقوامها فرقه زائد لوائين تقاتل
في تلك المنطقه باي باي هدف مش السيطره
الهدف السيطره على البريج لكن بعد مرور
عده ايام لم تستطع ان تحقق هذه النتيجه
عندما لم تستطع ان تسيطر على البريج دخلت
من المنطقه الجنوبيه ثم تراجعت الى منطقه
المقبره الان
حاولوا يعيدوا مره ثانيه الهجوم من الفجوه
ما بين البريج والنصيرات وحققوا فيها تقدم
بداوا الان يهاجموا البريج من الجهه
الغربيه والنصيرات من الجهه الشرقيه
وعملوا عمليه احاطه بداوا يهاجموا
الصيارات من الجهه الغربيه ل نعم واضح انه
بهدف السيطره لكن ماذا
يمثل مخيم البريج على على المستوى العسكري
الاهميه العسكريه له في سيا الان هذه ه
هذه تعتبر عقده الوسط ما بين الشمال
والجنوب وبالتالي هي تحاول ان تسيطر على
كافه المناطق المنطقه الوحيده التي لا
يوجد فيها قتال ارضي بمعنى قتال ارضي
منطقه دير البلح ما عدا ذلك منطقه خانيونس
يوجد سبعه الويه في النسق الاول ولوين في
النسق الثاني والمنطقه المخيمات في الوسط
يوجد الفرقه 36 مدعومه بلوائي وكتائب نخبه
هي تريد ان تسيطر على هذه المنطقه وتدخل
هذه المنطقه تحت هي تقول تريد ان تقضي على
المقاتلين وتدمر شبكه الانفاق هذا الهدف
المعلن لكن هي تدمر كل شيء وتهجر كل
المواطنين كيف تقيم اي عمليات المقاومه
يعني في اكثر من منطقه كانت هناك اشتباكات
هناك اعلانات لكتائب القسام ولسي القدس عن
عن استهدافات وهناك ايضا استهداف ب لطائره
اي بصاروخ مضاد ل الطائرات وهي طائره هرمز
9 هرمز هرمز هذه احد طائرات الاستطلاع
تعتبر هي ال في سلم التطور هي تاتي رقم
اثنين هي من حيث الذه ولديها القدره
الطيران ست ساعات لا مزوده
بكاميرات تنقل صور
مباشره تقدم صور لقد
في البعد الاستخباري لكشف الانفاق
وبالتالي تعتبر جزء رئيسي من المعركه فتم
فتم استهدافها
بصاروخ طيب هذا يعتبر تطور يعني تطور في
القدرات ل ليست المره الا هذ هذ هذه
مزامره للعمليات العسكريه لكن التطور جاء
منذ تقريبا اسبوع بد بدء استخدام الصواريخ
من قبل المقاومه سواء سام سب او 18 هذا
امر جديد لم نكن معتادين عليه في بدايه
المعركه او بدايه الحرب لكن في الاسبوع
الاخير كان هناك اسقاط اربعه طائرات وهذه
الطائره رقم خمسه التي يتم استهدافها ربما
ربما يسال
البعض او يعتبر ان هناك نوع من التاخير
مثلا في استخدام هذه الاسلحه ما الهدف من
التدرج لدى المقاومه في استخدام ما لديها
من قدرات يعني الان هذا السؤال له
نجيب بطريقه لانه لا نملك المعلومه الان
قد تكون هناك معوقات معينه من حيث العدد
من
اي هذا تقييم القائد الميداني هو الذي
يقرر انا لا نملك المعلومه لماذا لم
يستخدم الصواريخ في الفتره الاولى وبدا
باستخدامها في هذه المرحله حقيقه لا
نستطيع لانه لا توجد معلومات عن عن ذلك
وبالتالي من يدير المعركه هو الوحيد الذي
يعرف لماذا استخدمها في هذه المرحله امم
طيب في ايضا سياق المعارك التي تجري في
اكثر من منطقه والاشتباكات التي تحصل الى
اي مدى يمكن
اعتبارها عمليات مشاغله اكثر منها عمليات
منع وتصدي
لتوغل لا هي مزيج من المعارك هي عمليه منع
وتصدي وبنفس الوقت هي
عمليه يعني
هناك مقاربات مختلفه حسب المنطقه الموجوده
فيها اذا ذهبنا الى الشمال كانت طريقه
القتال مختلفه ليش لماذا لانه عمليه
المباني وكثافه المباني فبدا باستخدام
الكمائن المتحركه الكمائن الثابته عمليات
الاستدراج اذا ذهبنا الى
الوسط يعني المنطقه المنطقه هي التي تحدد
طريقه القتال شكرا لك اللواء فيز دويري
الخبير العسكري